dans la reconduction en 2013 suscite des
interrogations
la question de la reconduction de la
pérennisation de ces mesures sont
d'actualité puisque les négociations
sont d'ores et déjà en cours
il en est de même proposé qui représente
une aide de 278 millions d'euros aux
agriculteurs domiens la réforme de ce
programme est l'occasion de mettre en
place une gouvernance de ce règlement
plus proche des producteurs ultramarins
en les associant à la rédaction des
circulaires et annexes définissant les
mesures osez vous comprenez madame la
ministre
l'inquiétude des dom il appartient au
gouvernement de jouer un rôle
déterminant dans la sauvegarde des
intérêts des départements d'outre-mer au
sein de l'union européenne
enfin madame la ministre se pose le
problème des accords dits de partenariat
économique qui sont souvent en
contradiction avec les stratégies de
développement régional cette discordance
entrave l'intégration des dom dans leur
environnement géographique la
réalisation sud d'un pacte figure parmi
les axes forts du fus mémorandum des rup
dont vous êtes signataire
s'agissant des ape ne faudrait-il pas
madame la ministre en réaliser une dès
maintenant
je vous remercie de votre attention pour
vous répondre la parole et est
maintenant à madame marie-luce penchard
ministre chargée de l'outre-mer ce pour
deux minutes madame la ministre
bienvenue merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice vous avez raison de
le souligner
l'année 2011 est une année charnière
pour l'outre-mer pour nos régions
ultrapériphériques parce que nous devons
renégocier le budget de l'union
nous devons aussi redéfinir les
politiques de l'union européenne en
direction de nos territoires nous aurons
à mettre en place les mémorandums qui
sont la stratégie de l'union en
direction nos territoires qui a des
dossiers importants comme leurs trois de
merde qu'il faudra engager et puis nous
avons aussi un volet institutionnel non
négligeable puisque nous devons
accompagner mayotte avec son changement
de statut et nous devons faire en sorte
que pour saint-barth ce soit une
réussite
alors sur les sujets que vous
évoquez je voudrais vous dire que nous
avons engagé un travail très important
avec les services les autres ministères
concernés et puis les services de la
commission notamment sur l'octroi de mer
puisque nous avons répondu aux
informations complémentaires qui nous
était donné par la commission et que
nous allons engager une étude pour
pouvoir pérenniser cet outil de
développement
nous avons engagé aussi une réflexion
sur la politique de cohésion pour tirer
des enseignements notamment par rapport
aux années antérieures et pour faire en
sorte que les acquis communautaires en
direction de nos régions soient prises
en compte et j'en pense en particulier à
la location de compensation des
contraintes de nous ruer sur
l'organisation commune des marchés pour
le sus la réforme conduite 2006 a permis
d'acter que les aides concernant le
secteur sucrier des dom été transférés
dans le policier à la date d'aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas d'inquiétude particulière ni
sur le principe même du procès alors
concernant les accords de partenariat
dont vous faites état
bien évidemment vous connaissez
l'engagement du gouvernement pour
défendre les intérêts de nos régions
ultrapériphériques nous sommes
particulièrement attentifs d'ailleurs le
chef de l'état a été amené à saisir la
commission lors de l'accord des pays
andins pour rappeler combien il était
important de prendre en compte cette
dimension de nos régions
ultrapériphériques demander des
compensations et surtout nous avons
d'ores et déjà posé le principe de
l'étude d'impact pour que ce soit fait
de manière systématique en amont de tous
les accords commerciaux
merci madame bien sûr aimé ministre
madame en euros si vous souhaitez
répondre à la ministre ou faire une
observation par rapport à la réponse que
vous avez eue je prends apparemment tout
est mis en route pour qu'on soit
tranquilliser pour que hans on dément
cette année avec toute quiétude
je veux bien voir par les actes dans les
mois à venir ce qu'il en sera merci bien
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
adrien giraud pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole mon cher
collègue
puis ciel président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues lors de ma dernière
intervention à la tribune de notre
assemblée en décembre 2010 à l'occasion
de la discussion des deux projets de loi
relatif au département de mayotte
j'ai réitéré notre demande de
participation au concours des fonds
structurels européens
véritable levier de développement
économique et social des diverses
collectivités
en décembre 2008 le président nicolas
sarkozy s'était engagé je les six à skis
une démarche auprès des institutions
communautaires pour la transformation de
mayotte en régions ultrapériphériques
interviennent dans des délais
compatibles à l'accès aux financements
européens qui sont mis à l'oeuvre à
partir de 2014 au terme de 10ème fed
cette ambition nous savons que vous la
partagez madame la ministre je car je
connais votre mobilisation au service de
progrès de mayotte envie notamment de
l'accession de notre nouveau département
du statut de région ultrapériphérique de
l'europe c'est-à-dire rup
une telle ambition vous l'avez exprimée
lors des différentes réunions et au
forum sur la périphérie européenne qui
se sont tenues au cours de l'année 2010
un travail intense de mise en conformité
tenant compte de nos spécificités v est
désormais engagée mais nécessite encore
de nombreuses négociations entre paris
et bruxelles
enfin que la démarche des représentants
maoré aboutissent dans les délais prévus
et permettez moi d'ajouter aussi
rapidement que possible
madame la ministre pouvez-vous des dés
aujourd'hui nous indiquer l'état des
négociations engagées entre le
gouvernement et la commission européenne
enfin que mayotte bénéficient des
concours financiers et techniques de
l'europe communautaire
je vous remercie de votre réponse qui
est très attendu par les mahorais merci
mon cher collègue pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame y
chargé de l'outre-mer marie-luce
penchard monsieur le président monsieur
le sénateur adrien giraud vous le savez
parfaitement le président de la
république lorsqu'il a reçu les élus
marc webb pour présenter le pacte de la
départementalisation a annoncé à ce
moment-là qu'il allait demander la
transformation de mayotte en régions
ultrapériphériques
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
vous avez bien compris que cet
engagement était affirmé lors du conseil
interministériel de l'outre-mer présidé
par nicolas sarkozy le 6 novembre 2009
et nous avons bien évidemment entériné
le voeu exprimé par les collectivités la
collectivité départementale en 2005 2007
et 2009
mais comme vous le savez nous pouvons
obtenir cette rupéïsation mayotte en
utilisant la procédure simplifiée
puisque le traité de lisbonne le prévoit
dans son article 3 156 c'est ce que nous
allons faire et cela vous le savez ça
doit se faire aussi avec la vie à
l'unanimité du conseil européen alors
d'ores et déjà je me suis entretenu à
plusieurs reprises avec les commissaires
en charge ces questions si bien le
commissaire hahn de l'arrêt et de la
direction régionale que le commissaire
pit bikes qui a les questions de
développement de manière à ce que nous
mettions ensemble des services qui
peuvent travailler sur ce sujet et nous
avons obtenu qui est unité rup au sein
de la direction générale régionale comme
service référent de manière à entamer ce
processus et nous avons tenu informé
régulièrement les services de la
commission sur le processus de
départementalisation de mayotte parce
que c'est un acte fort pour permettre
effectivement de voir que mayotte pour
aller vers ce droit commun alors cette
ces échanges se sont traduit aussi par
des réunions de travail on a eu en
novembre 2009 y en a eu en 25 le 25 juin
2010 il ya une réunion très importante à
la fin de ce mois est d'ores et déjà
vous savez que nous avons demandé à
associer mayotte aux travaux concernant
les régions ultrapériphériques en tant
qu'observateur et moi même lors de la
dernière réunion des rup aux canaries en
octobre 2010 j'ai a accueilli avec
beaucoup de satisfaction
la déclaration du commissaire
à qui effectivement rappelait comme il
ya un mayotte devait assister à notre
avant donc nous tenons nos engagements
nous sommes déterminés pour que mayotte
puissent accéder à ce statut durup le
calendrier sera connu au cours du mois
de mai merci merci madame anne marie
payet pour s'adresse à madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre la question de mon collègue
adrien giraud porté sur la mise en
oeuvre effective d'un engagement du
président de la république
dans le même esprit je souhaiterais
avoir des précisions sur l'entrée en
vigueur des mesures tendant à simplifier
le régime des visas court séjour pour
l'autre mais ces mesures très attendues
figure parmi les engagements du premier
conseil interministériel de l'outre-mer
du 6 novembre 2009
elles doivent permettre de moderniser le
régime actuel en vertu duquel les
étrangers titulaires d'un visa schengen
doivent obtenir le visa spécifique pour
se rendre à la réunion où dans chacun
des autres territoires d'outre-mer le 10
janvier 2010 le président de la
république jugé depuis saint denis qui
n'est plus acceptable que pour avoir un
visa lorsqu'on est d'un pays limitrophes
pour visiter la réunion on doive
demander une autorisation à paris qui
doit revenir à la réunion
un an après madame la ministre pouvez
vous indiquer au sénat dans quelle
mesure dans quel délai les mesures
d'assouplissement prévu entreront en
vigueur je remercie je pense que vous
profiterez tête d'un moment pour
répondre à madame payet teller à sa
question
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
monsieur eric doligé bon le gros homme
excusez moi monsieur daniel marsin pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen suis allé voir le
président
monsieur madame la ministre que mes
chers collègues c'est pour moi
aujourd'hui l'occasion d'aborder
j'allais dire de nouveau la question
cruciale de l'impact des accords de
libre échange et négocié par l'union
européenne avec les pays tiers sur les
économies ultramarines et d'ailleurs sur
l'économie française en général
en effet je vous avais aller a déjà
alerté sur cette question en évoquant la
signature des accords entre l'union
européenne la colombie et le pérou
à cette époque il n'était pas encore
signé
même si la situation est déjà
préoccupante avec des effets prévisibles
des sculpteurs pour les économies de nos
jeux et les trois périphériques
aujourd'hui la machine infernale s'est
déjà enclenché en effet lors du sommet
de madrid
cet accord a été paraphé ce qui a
constitué un précédent d'ailleurs
immédiatement prolongée par la
finalisation d'accords commerciaux avec
les pays d'amérique centrale et kidal en
ouvre un boulevard pour les négociations
actuellement en cours avec les pays du
mercosur
si l'ensemble de ces accords étaient
conclus il s'agirait alors d'un
véritable coup de grâce pollock pour
l'agriculture ultramarine
force est de constater que dans ces
circonstances la voix de l'outre-mer
n'est pas entendue et des objectifs
communautaires qui prennent en compte en
principe les handicaps structurels de
territoires ultramarins sont carrément
ignoré les parlementaires ultramarins à
paris comme à bruxelles d'ailleurs n'ont
pourtant pas cessé depuis plus depuis
depuis tantôt de tirer la signer la
sonnette d'alarmé
que faire pour enrayer cette spirale
infernale frais d'une pas prévenir en
posant les intérêts des rues comme
contrainte dans les positions adoptées
par les négociateurs communautaire lors
de ces négociations et d'autre part
intégrer des compensation additionnelle
dans la révision du du posei alors
madame la ministre je voudrais que vous
puissiez nous nous dire de quelle marge
de manoeuvre disposez vous réellement et
dans ce cadre de quelles initiatives
comptez-vous prendre afin d'éviter le
naufrage programmé de la culture il
travaille
sur bercy pour répondre à monsieur
martin la parole est à madame marie-luce
penchard ministre chargée de l'outremer
devait la parole merci monsieur
président invente répond nos sénateurs
marcin je voudrais simplement dire à
madame la sénatrice anne marie payet que
s'agissant de l'assouplissement des
visant c'est bien le gouvernement de
françois fillon avec l'impulsion du chef
de l'état qui a souhaité prendre en
compte la dimension environnementale de
nos régions puisque nous avons respecté
nos engagements lors du conseil
interministériel de l'outre-mer puisque
150 mesures d'assouplissement des visas
doit permettre d'assouplir je dirais la
circulation des personnes et des biens
et que s'agissant de la réunion nous
sommes actuellement en négociations pour
faire de la réunion une destination
touristique regard effectivement de la
chine et de l'afrique du sud donc nous
poursuivons le travail et j'espère que
nous y arriverons dans les prochains
mois alors monsieur marcel nous
interroger sur la question effectivement
des accords commerciaux et de la
négociation de ces accords bien
évidemment nous avons un souci
particulier de défendre les intérêts des
régions ultrapériphériques nous l'avons
fait déjà puisque dans le cadre de
l'accord de partenariat économique vous
savez que nous avons obtenus notamment
le principe d'une clause de skovgaard
régionaliser qui nous permet de
restaurer les droits de douane
antérieures lorsqu on apporte la preuve
comme quoi y'a perturbation du marché
local d'une rue et également nous
pouvons maintenir des droits de douane
sur les marchés locaux notamment pour le
sucre et la banane et cela vous le savez
c'est possible depuis 2008 sur une
période de deux fois dix ans c'est un
premier pas c'est pas suffisant il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin en tout cas le
président de la république n'a pas
hésité vous le savez s'agissant de
l'accord en d'intervenir personnellement
puisqu'il a écrit au président barroso
pour dire combien il était inimaginable
d'imposer à nos régions
ultrapériphériques des contraintes aussi
forte sans envisager des contreparties
de même ampleur je le cite et nous avons
demandé à ce titre des compensations
c'est en cours d'instruction
mais monsieur le sénateur ans que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que
effectivement nous devons
aller plus loin nous devons faire en
sorte que nos régions ultrapériphériques
et notre agriculture ne soit pas une
variable d'ajustement c'est pour cela
que nous avons d'ores et déjà exigé
qu'ils aient des études d'impact
préalable à tout accord entre l'union
européenne et les pays acp cp en
particulier merci monsieur marc st pour
répondre la ministre oui je voudrais
remercier la vénus de sa réponse qui
m'ont qui semblait indiquer que le
gouvernement a parfaitement conscience
de la nécessité de préserver les
intérêts de l'outre-mer en tout état de
cause ce que je souhaite pour terminer
sur cette question c'est que un mandat
clair explicite soit donnée à la
représentation permanente de la france
auprès de l'union européenne pour
assurer en toutes circonstances une
défense des intérêts des outre-mer dans
la phase de négociation de ces accords
commerciaux et plus généralement qu'on
arrive à faire admettre que des accords
ne puissent être passés sans qu'on ne
font que ça qu'on est posée comme une
contrainte
la défense des intérêts de camama merci
de parler maintenant monsieur eric
doligé pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire monsieur religieux
est aussi le rapporteur du comité de
suivi de l'outre-mer au sénat mme merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je souhaite vous interroger sur un seul
sujet l'avenir de l'octroi de mer
ce régime et spécifiques à l'outre-mer
il revient à frapper les marchandises
introduite dans les départements
d'outre-mer d'une taxe à laquelle
échappe certaines productions locales
il représente à la fois une ressource
fiscale majeure pour les collectivités
territoriales des départements
d'outre-mer et un soutien décisif où le
développement endogène de ces
collectivités
ainsi rapporté à l'ensemble des recettes
de fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales l'octroi de mer représente
en moyenne pour les communes des
départements d'outre-mer un tiers de
leurs recettes et pour les régions
d'outremer entre 17 et 31 %
il est même des communes guyanaise
le crois de mer représente 90% des
recettes fiscales
ce dispositif largement perçue dans les
instances communautaires comme contraire
au principe de non discrimination est
aujourd'hui menacé en effet par une
décision de 2004 le conseil a autorisé
la france à maintenir un tel régime
d'octroi jusqu'au 1er juillet 2014 comme
elle s'y était engagée les autorités
françaises ont transmis à la commission
un rapport d'étape en 2008 puis un
rapport complémentaire en avril 2010
pour lui permettre de juger de l'impact
de l'octroi de mer et suggérer des
adaptations de ce régime
la commission européenne a jugé que les
données fournies par la france était
lacunaire
elle reconnaît toutefois que les
handicaps des départements d'outre-mer
persiste mais elle reste sceptique sur
les conséquences d'une taxation
différenciée des produits locaux elle
souligne que l'incidence de l'octroi de
mer sur l'emploi ou sur les parts de
marché des productions locales diffèrent
sensiblement selon les secteurs
la commission a néanmoins proposé le 14
décembre dernier d'adapter la décision
du conseil de 2004 et d'élargir le
bénéfice de l'octroi de mer à une
cinquantaine de produits yann est une
bonne nouvelle pour la guyane notre
région ultrapériphérique la plus
défavorisée
mais les interrogations répétées de la
commission européenne sur le bien-fondé
de l'octroi de mer et sur son incidence
sur le niveau général des prix dans les
dom ne peuvent manquer d'inquiéter pour
l'avenir je sais votre mobilisation pour
pérenniser l'octroi de mer mais
suffira-t-elle à convaincre la
commission de la proroger après 2014
la france sera t elle en mesure de
fournir les informations étayées
qu'attend la commission est de trouver
des alliés au conseil
merci pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame la ministre chargée de
l'outre-mer vous avez la parole réglisse
messieurs président monsieur le sénateur
doligé
j'ai envie de vous répondre tout
simplement oui j'y crois
le plus profondément pourquoi parce que
d'abord vous savez la commission a bien
pris conscience que l'outil octroi de
mer était vraiment un outil de
développement économique et que c'était
aussi
une façon de protéger l'emploi j'y crois
pourquoi parce que même si dans le
rapport la commission a fait un certain
nombre d'observations en disant
effectivement que la part des marchés
pris par les produits locaux n'est pas
si importante où elle est équivalente
aux produits importés mais elle a fait
surtout remarquer et c'est ça qui est un
point positif que s'il n'y avait pas eu
l'octroi de mer bon nombre d'activités
n'existerait pas donc c'est un signe
qu'elle nous envoie en plus je vois par
l'information que m'a apporté
personnellement le commissaire semeta
qui m'a appelé pour me dire que la
commission avait adopté les conclusions
de ce rapport montrent aujourd'hui que
la commission voit l'intérêt de l'outil
pour nos régions ultrapériphériques
cela étant le deuxième objectif qui doit
être le nôtre
je pense que le principe est acté au
niveau de l'europe simplement nous
devons pouvoir justifier de cet octroi
de mer c'est tout le sens de la mission
que j'ai engagées sur la base des
décisions qui ont été prises lors du
conseil interministériel de l'outre-mer
pour que nous examinions exactement le
comparatif entre les prix des produits
locaux avec les prix des produits
importés et que nous puissions apporter
tous les justificatifs qui permettent à
la fois de bien prendre en compte que au
travers de cet outil notre volonté c'est
de développer l'activité
c'est d'asseoir le développement
endogène et c'est de préserver l'emploi
je crois que les collectivités s'associe
à cette réflexion puisque dans le cadre
de cette étude
j'ai souhaité qu'il puisse participer à
l'élaboration du cahier des charges et
qu'ils seront membres du comité de
pilotage et je suis tout à fait disposé
à recevoir d'autres éléments puisque il
ya le conseil régional de la réunion et
de la guyane qui sont en train de mener
des études
nous devons être tous ensemble pour
apporter le maximum d'éléments à la
commission et je suis persuadé avec ces
éléments que la commission donnera un
avis favorable pour pérenniser l'octroi
de mer après 2014
c'est le liger
porter le président je dois dire que je
suis très satisfait de la réponse parce
qu'en 2008 lorsque nous nous sommes
rendus à bruxelles avec l'émission
n'était pas aussi persuadé
qu'aujourd'hui que la situation où la
réponse de la commission serait
probablement favorable nous avions pu
constater à l'époque en rencontrant nos
représentants à bruxelles qu'il y avait
un certain flottement sur ce dossier et
qu'ils étaient peut-être pas non plus
neutre est persuadé du dossier qu'il
défend des jeux le sentiment que les
choses ont évolué dans le bon sens et
que le chemin qui n'avait peut-être pas
été parcouru jusqu'à 2008 s'est
largement accéléré vers une solution
positive donc merci madame la ministre
nous nous passer de façon si chaleureuse
votre conviction donc je n'y croyais pas
en 2008 j'y crois aujourd'hui suite à
votre intervention
merci merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue serge larcher pour le
groupe socialiste serge larcher
président le comité de suivi de la
mission d'information sur la situation
de l'autre aubert il avait la parole mon
cher collègue le président madame la
ministre
mieux serait de revenir sur les accords
de libre échange conclus par l'union
européenne au printemps 2010 avec
certains pays d'amérique du sud et vous
interroger sur les mesures sont garde
dont la responsabilité incombe au
gouvernement français à mai dernier à
l'occasion des questions d'actualité je
vous avait alerté sur l'impact
potentiellement dévastateurs pour les
économies des départements d'outre-mer
de l'accord signé en mars 2010 entre
l'union européenne la colombie et le
pérou
cet accord lève en effet des barrières
douanières en matière de produits
industriels et agricoles
il permet notamment l'entrée dans
l'union européenne et dans les
départements d'outre-mer de certains
produits issus des pays aux coûts de
production largement inférieurs or
certains de nouveau de ses produits tels
que la banane le sucre le rhum
j'ajouterai l'igname aussi structure
que de nos départements d'outre-mer cet
accord fragilise donc le secteur
agricole secteur pivot des économies
d'eau miel est d'ailleurs consacrée
comme un des secteurs clés du
développement endogène de ces derniers
par la loi de développement économique
des outre mer lodeom de questions à ce
propos du pape quelles initiatives à
nouveau prises ou comptez-vous prendre
madame la ministre a fait que le
préjudice causé aux départements
d'outre-mer soit prise en compte au
niveau européen et fassent l'objet des
compensations nécessaires à ce titre
pouvons nous espérer que la proposition
de règlement dit posei que la commission
soumise au conseil soit complété par des
dispositions concrétisant cette
compensation
d'autre part de tel accord pourrait être
à terme étendue à l'ensemble des pays
d'amérique latine
parallèlement les négociations avec le
mercosur ont été prononcées par la
commission européenne qui affiche
l'ambition de conclure d'ici quelques
mois
quelle île certaines comptez-vous
prendre madame l'année ça fait que le
devenir des débardeurs des départements
comme air ne sont pas une fois encore
sacrifié sur l'autel des intérêts de
l'industrie et aux pme
merci pour répondre au président larcher
la parole est à madame penchard ministre
chargée de l'outre-mer ah si monsieur le
président monsieur sénateurs larcher
le gouvernement prend beaucoup
d'initiatives pour défendre l'intérêt de
région ultrapériphérique dans las
période qui s'ouvre
simplement ce que je voudrais vous dire
en préambule il est beaucoup plus
difficile aujourd'hui de négocier
puisque nous sommes six états membres
concernés à la fois par des régions
ultrapériphériques ou dpi théo mpt om
les plus difficile de négocier à 27 que
lorsque nous étions à 15
donc cette donnée là il faut bien
l'intégrer et que nous en sommes dans
une période charnière comme je répondais
à la sénatrice hoarau parce que nous
devons renégocier toutes les politiques
de l'union européenne et d'autres
être particulièrement vigilants en tout
cas je ne ménagerai pas mes efforts
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'essaie
de faire en sorte que le gouvernement
est une très grande visibilité sur
l'action qu'il entend mener pour
défendre les régions ultrapériphériques
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
intervenu pour que dans la stratégie qui
va être arrêté et sa stratégie elle va
être basé à partir de quoi des
conclusions du mémorandum nous
inscrivions dès à présent le principe
des études d'impact systématique et que
nous puissions faire en sorte que les
clauses de sauvegarde puisse fonctionner
parce que si elles existent et qu'elles
ont été posées lors des négociations
dans le cadre des ape
nous ne savons pas aujourd'hui déclenché
ce mécanisme et nous devons rechercher
les critères qui nous permettront de
donner des éléments à la commission pour
montrer à un moment donné qu
effectivement notre production est en
danger c'est l'objet de
l'expérimentation que nous faisons à la
réunion sur un certain nombre de
produits agricoles et à partir de cette
expérimentation dès lors que nous
pourrons le faire valoir la commission
nous allons proposer que ce soit étendu
je dirais dans l'ensemble de nos
départements et régions d'outre-mer
voyez le gouvernement de la france agit
s'agissant effectivement de ces régions
ultrapériphériques en lien avec les
autres pays des états membres concernés
mais sur d'autres sujets bien évidemment
je pourrais vous indiquer comment nous
sommes présents et nous le serons
pendant toute la phase de négociation
puisque la période charnière vous le
savez ça va être précisément entre juin
et juillet date à laquelle nous aurons
effectivement les grandes orientations
de la politique de cohésion territoriale
et nous aurons enfin les perspectives
budgétaires et financières de l'union
européenne pour la prochaine mandature
jeu président larcher
mais ma valise retrouvée à vos côtés sur
le pont pour défendre l'intérêt des
parties très bien ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que yvon comme disait que ça il
vaut toujours mieux prévenir que guérir
il aurait mieux valu exclut d'emblée
avant les marchés les marchés locaux et
par d'autres maires de l'ensemble des
accords de libre échange
et puis autre chose c'est que il faut
savoir que l'igname les produits virique
des produits vivriers productions
vivrières et maraîchères sont déjà
menacés par l'instruction venant du
costa rica et du brésil en ce moment et
par conséquent quand on sait que le
dentiste ou sur la route de ces grands
ensembles à allant vers l'europe et bien
brossés bien ils vont inonder une
production et mettre à mal notre notre
filière écoles et ce faisant détruire
cette cette filière et en même temps
d'être au chômage et nombre de cultures
d'autres choses bien sûr il faut des
compensations c'est le moins qu'on
puisse espérer mais les compensations ce
sont des moyens financiers qui vit par
mu par malheur dieu dans le temps et
risque de disparaître
par conséquent c'est une impasse
manquons mai soit un mal qui risque
durable
c'est pour cette raison je vous dis que
vous aimez vous allez avoir à vos côtés
tous l'ensemble dès élus de l'outre-mer
pour défendre l'intérêt fondamental de
leurs deux du production qui est
essentiel pour le développement endogène
de nos territoires
je remercie merci il est maintenant
notre collègue ibrahim ramadani pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
seul président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues ma question rejoint
celle de mon collègue adrien de mayotte
en effet le pacte pour la
départementalisation de mayotte précise
que l'état engagera très rapidement une
démarche auprès des institutions
communautaires
pour que la transformation de mayotte en
régions ultrapériphériques intervient
dans des délais compatibles avec l'accès
aux financements européens
disponible à partir de 2014
cette démarche madame la ministre vous
l'avait mené et l'engagement qui est le
vôtre et de transmettre aux autorités
communautaires la demande officielle de
la france visant à la transformation de
mayotte actuellement pays et territoires
d'outre-mer en régions
ultrapériphériques de lieu dans le
courant du second semestre 2011
cette évolution du statut européen de
mayotte permettra à l'île de rattraper
ses retards en matière d'infrastructures
et d'équipements collectifs apportera
plus de soutiens collectivités locales
encouragera la sauvegarde des langues de
mayotte garantira le respect des droits
fondamentaux favorisera l'insertion de
mayotte dans son environnement régional
direct j'ai déposé auprès de la
présidence du sénat une demande de
constitution et d'envoi d'une mission
d'information sanitaire sénatoriale à
mayotte pour étudier l'impact économique
social et culturel de cette évolution
la question est la suivante
madame la ministre pourriez vous nous
assurez du respect du calendrier évoqué
par vous même c'est à dire de
transmettre à l'union européenne la
demande officielle de la france visant à
transformer mayotte en rup dans le
courant du second semestre 2011
je vous remercie pour vos l'état madame
marie-luce penchard ministre de
l'outre-mer président avant de répondre
au sénateur et ibrahim ramadani puisque
nous sommes dans un débat sur l'europe
je voudrais apporter la précision au
sénateur larcher pour lui dire
qu'effectivement sa proposition est
particulièrement pertinente simplement
je voudrais laurent leur envoyer à la
lecture du mémorandum qui soulève cette
question parce que de par nos statuts
nous faisons partie du marché intérieur
et à ce titre le droit européen
s'applique et au regard d'un autre
statut il ya parfois des
incompatibilités a bénéficié à la fois
de la politique sectorielle et à faire
valoir l'article 349 qui nous permet de
déroger un certain nombre de
dispositions et c'est toute la réflexion
que d'ailleurs a lancé le commissaire
barnier quand il dit que veut dire
marché intérieur au niveau de notre
l'union européenne et ce qui peut pas y
avoir des marchés intérieurs
régionalisés donc c'est un long des
banques pourraient continuer sur ce
point alors s'agissant de mayotte et en
complément de ce que je viens de dire je
voudrais vous rassurer monsieur le
sénateur nous allons demander cette rue
p cette transformation du statut de
mayotte au conseil à l'union européenne
dans le calendrier que nous nous sommes
fixés mais nous devons préalablement
mesurer les écarts notamment entre le
droit applicable à mayotte et le droit
européen
bien évidemment la départementalisation
en mars 2011 est une première étape mais
là dessus moi je voudrais vous rassurer
il y aura forcément un écart puisque au
moment où la demande sera formulée nous
n'aurons pas un droit complètement
applicable à mayotte mais cela nous
permettra quand même de faire la demande
puisque nous pourrons faire valoir les
dispositions de l'article 349 du traité
alors je veux vous rassurer le
calendrier est le suivant comme nous
avons mis des commissions de travail
entre les mets services des ministères
concernés les services de la commission
nous avons une réunion
une troisième réunion à la fin de ce
mois fin mars nous devons officialisé la
demande de la france et elle devrait
normalement être adressé officiellement
au conseil à la fin du mois de mai donc
nous avons vraiment cette volonté de
respecter le
le calendrier parce que vous le savez
mieux que moi ça fait partie du pacte
pour la départementalisation
parce que si nous voulons que mayotte
puisse se développer il faut que nous
puissions mobiliser très rapidement les
fonds structurels dans le cadre des
prochains programmes opérationnels et
moi une roma n'a ni si vous avez
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je suis tout à fait
satisfait de cette réponse d'autant plus
qu'elle complète celle qui précède posée
par vraiment collègues adrien giraud
merci merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
georges patient
pour le groupe socialiste la parole mon
cher collègue monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
madame la ministre je souhaite vous
interroger sur l'application aveugle des
normes européennes dans les départements
d'outre-mer et ce en dépit des
dispositions de l'article 349 du traité
de lisbonne qui le reconnaît un statut
dérogatoire au régime communautaire
commun à partir de quelques exemples
révélateurs je vais illustrer mes propos
le premier exemple concerne
l'application des normes européennes en
matière de carburant en guyane qui a
conduit ce territoire à s'approvisionner
aujourd'hui en europe du nord a un coût
jugé excessif localement
quand on sait qu'il pourrait être
approvisionnées dans son environnement
régional à un coût nettement moindre
actuellement le litre d'essence est de 1
euro 53 en guyane alors qu'il est de
moins de 1 euro surinam c'est aussi le
cas de la pêche compterait dans son
développement par des règles européennes
qui interdisent notamment de
subventionner la construction de navires
alors que dans les dom
contrairement à la situation dans les
départements métropolitains la filière
et la shdm artisanale la ressource
halieutique abondante la demande
conséquente
c'est aussi le cas du secteur rizicole
fillier nom puis en guyane
qui souffre notamment de l'application
inapproprié de certification européenne
alors que le riz produit dans les pays
voisins guyana surinam fabrique avec des
semences non homologué euros et vendu en
europe
je pourrais aussi parler de la question
des déchets les exactement pain et sont
loin d'épuiser la liste des nuisances
normative pour l'autre mère qui créent
des distorsions de concurrence au
détriment de secteurs économiques dont
l'activité est ouverte sur les pays
voisins renforcer la prise en compte des
spécificités régions ultrapériphériques
par l'union européenne telle était la
proposition 62 de la mission
d'information sénatoriale sur la
situation des dom améliorer l'adaptation
des normes communauté en réalité locale
à renforcer la mise en oeuvre de
l'article 289 2 du traité c'est eux
c'était aussi la mesure 6,5 du conseil
interministériel de l'outre-mer du 6
novembre 2009
pourtant la commission européenne dans
la ministre ne nous a pas suivis dans
votre demande de dérogation pour le
carburant de guyane en la rejetant en
décembre 2009
alors madame la ministre au delà des
bonnes intentions existe il de la part
du gouvernement une réelle volonté
d'intervenir sur la commission
européenne réticente jusqu'à présent
pour que soient concrétisés les
dispositions de l'article 349 euros
merci pour répondre à monsieur patients
la parole est à mme adam reed usma
charlize de l'outre-mer monsieur
sénateurs vous savez mieux que moi que
la petite 349 constitue en quelque sorte
un droit des mesures spécifiques toute
la difficulté aujourd'hui est notre
obligation d'agir c'est de savoir
comment faire jouer l'article 349 par
rapport notamment à cet imbroglio où à
la fois nous sommes à l'intérieur du
marché européen et en même temps nous
avons des régions qui se développe dans
un environnement régional complètement
différent alors moi ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire c'est que sur ce sujet je me
suis entretenu à plusieurs reprises avec
les différents commissaires et que la
réflexion avance parce que notamment sur
l'idée de marché intérieur régionaliser
c'est là dessus qu'on va pouvoir
travailler différemment notamment pour
qu'ils aient des normes spécifiques non
pas prédit simplement pour l'europe
occidentale mais pour nos régions
ultrapériphériques alors
tout ça est vue dans le cadre des
préconisations et des propositions qui
figurent dans le mémorandum moi je
voudrais surtout vous répondre à partir
d'un certain nombre de sujets que vous
avez évoqué sur le carburant il n'y a
pas de refus aujourd'hui de principe de
la commission européenne pour proposer
un cadre dérogatoire acceptable c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons fait une
étude sur la disponibilité des
carburants aux normes européennes à
proximité de la guyane est aujourd'hui
nous n'en avons aucune assurance
simplement nous savons que nous avons
des carburants qui sont proches de ces
normes il faudra aujourd'hui apporter la
preuve à la commission que si nous
faisons ce choix il faudrait pas que ce
soit un impact négatif réel sur
l'environnement ou la santé parce que ce
sont des sujets de préoccupation de
l'europe mais moi je voudrais vous
inviter aussi à prendre en compte la
réflexion qui a été menée par les trois
présidents de région au travers de
l'urag et qui a décidé de maintenir
l'outil sarah donc à un moment il faudra
faire des choix et des priorités sur la
filière riz j'ai bien pris en compte
effectivement votre observation et nous
travaillons avec la commission
européenne sur ce sujet particulière et
d'une manière générale sur les
productions agricoles
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure il faut
apprendre à structurer les filières il
faut faire en sorte que notre
agriculture notre père ne soit pas une
variable d'ajustement lors de ces
négociations et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai demandé au commissaire au
développement endogène qui ont été
récemment nommé de travailler en lien
avec les ambassadeurs pour que cette
dimension soient prises en compte lors
des différentes négociations des accords
commerciaux ont quelques secondes pour
permettre le monsieur gillot
2 oui j cette question madame la
ministre
j'ai écouté attentivement votre réponse
mais je crois qu'il faut reconnaître que
l'union européenne a fait actuellement
le choix de gomme et peu à peu les
différences de traitement et les
avantages de bénéficier nos territoires
sous couvert de libération des échanges
de restriction budgétaire et de
changements de priorités vers d'autres
zones régionales dans le monde
donc mes collègues vous en parlais tout
à l'heure des difficultés avec les
accords conclus avec le pérou et la
colombie sur le problème de bananes
d'igname mais dont il faut reconnaître
non plus que les analyses d'impact dont
vous parlez ont fait défaut et la
commission européenne ne l'a pas proposé
de compensation supplémentaire
en tout état de cause on peut douter de
la détermination de la commission
européenne et des états de mettre en
danger de tels accords pour protéger nos
petits territoires d'outre-mer il ne
reste plus maintenant qu'au gouvernement
français espagnol et portugais de
trouver de nouvelles alliances dans une
europe à 27 et de conditionner leur
accord sur les grandes réformes
européennes à venir dans un essai des
dispositions des traités en faveur de
l'outre-mer comme du principe de
solidarité que fonde le projet européen
mais aussi la parole est maintenant
notre collègue jacques gillot pour le
groupe socialiste devait la parole merci
président madame la ministre je souhaite
vous interroger sur la politique de
cohésion pour l'outre-mer nous sommes à
la veille de la réforme de la politique
de cohésion européenne qui va intervenir
dans un cadre budgétaire européen
assurément contraint la commission
annoncée en novembre 2010 les
orientations qu'elle entend proposer
pour les fonds structurels après 2013
c'est un enjeu important pour nos
régions ultrapériphériques qui reçoit
pour la période 2007-2013 une enveloppe
de 3,2 milliards d'euros au titre de
l'objectif couvert j'en dis objectif 1
les quatre nommés nestea incident
programme aux tic du fonds européen de
développement régional feder et au titre
du fonds social européen fse en fonction
de leur niveau de pib par habitant
il est vrai que le traité de lisbonne a
consacré la triple dimension de la
cohésion économique sociale et
territoriale
néanmoins la combinaison des critères
d'éligibilité et de la baisse du pib
moyen de lui
on suit à l'élargissement suscite
l'inquiétude de certaines régions de la
périphérie est susceptible de ne plus
être éligible comme à la martinique
en août il est légitime de se préoccuper
de l'avenir de l'allocation spécifique
rue qui constitue une dotation
complémentaire du feder baptisé
allocation de compensation des surcoûts
liés aux handicaps structurels
quelles actions madame la ministre anne
et vous menez pour assurer la continuité
de ces fonds européen après 2013 et
soutenir ainsi le développement de nos
départements d'outre-mer
par ailleurs le taux de consommation des
crédits européens dans les dom reste
insuffisant certains l'expliquent par la
rigidité qu'introduit la règle
européenne du fléchage des subventions
dans l'utilisation de ces fonds tre me
rappelais earmarking pouvez vous
m'indiquer dans quelle mesure madame la
ministre l'a contraint durant ma sûrs
earmarking pourraient être levés afin de
nous permettre grâce à une meilleure
concentration des fonds communautaires
de pons une autre étape
notre rattrapage de sculpture elle en
équipement de base dans le domaine des
déchets de l'eau et de l'assainissement
par exemple comptez-vous à cet effet
prendre des initiatives pour associer
les élus locaux ultra marins au pilotage
stratégique des fonds structurels
je vois ma psy pour répondre à monsieur
gillioz la parole est à mme anna marie
luce penchard ministre chargée de
l'outremer devait la parole mais
l'analyste
monsieur sénateur vous abordez un des
points essentiels pour nos régions
ultrapériphériques c'est tout le débat
qui va y avoir lieu très prochainement
sur les perspectives financières et
budgétaires c'est en cours ce sera connu
à partir du mois de juillet ce que je
peux vous dire dès à présent c'est que
s'agissant de région ultrapériphérique
qui sont dans l'objectif de convergence
numéro un
on a bon espoir de pouvoir maintenir les
enveloppes nous devons être
particulièrement vigilants vous l'avez
souligné
pour les territoires qui risquent de
sortir de cet objectif de convergence
nous avons déjà pris une initiative avec
d'autres états membres qui sont
concernés par des régions qui sont dans
la même situation que la martinique pour
faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
traitement particulier de manière à leur
permettent de bénéficier en compte des
fonds structurels mais
je dirais la démarche sera difficile
nous en avons conscience c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ores et déjà le
gouvernement français a demandé
s'agissant des régions
ultrapériphériques le maintien de
l'allocation compensation du handicap
parce qu'il n'est pas envisageable que
nous puissions perdre le bénéfice de
cette allocation
et puis au niveau de la mobilisation des
crédits dont vous faites état
il est vrai que lorsqu'on regarde la
situation même si les taux d'engagement
sont satisfaisants nous devons pouvoir
avoir une meilleure consommation de ces
crédits si nous voulons maintenir ces
enveloppes
les commissaires ont appelé mon
attention à plusieurs reprises et c'est
la raison pour laquelle tout le travail
qui fait actuellement dans le cadre de
la révision à mi parcours de ces
programmes
il y a une volonté de réorienter les
opérations étaient programmés pour être
sûr de pouvoir mobiliser les crédits et
même la martinique a fait le choix de
limiter le nombre des opérations et
d'aller vers un taux d'intervention
beaucoup plus important je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une vraie volonté
de la commission de nous accompagner
je pense qu'on peut sortir du critère de
l'économie de la connaissance pour
prendre en compte les grandes
infrastructures
maintenant je crois que nous devons
ensemble montrer que nous sommes
capables de mobiliser les fonds
européens pour pouvoir maintenir les
enveloppes en est à destination des
régions ultrapériphériques répondre et
faire entendre d'autres préoccupations
la parole et 20 autres collègues gens
inquiets d'un problème merci monsieur le
président élu c'est vraiment parce que
j'ai le plaisir de conclure quelques
observations
s'ils sauvaient le 6 pour sauver le
soldat la sara et nous devons maintenir
des flambées des prix donc de l'essence
en guyane
rassurez-vous nous allons sacrifier ses
pétroliers parce que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter le prix donc du carburant en
l'état actuellement par rapport à votre
réponse concernant la question du
collègue gillot je crois que si ce qui
convient de retenir
madame la mini c'est que force est de
constater que malheureusement nous ne
pouvons pas consommer un certain nombre
donc de lignes budgétaires tout
simplement parce que le département
d'outre-mer dans pourquoi réaliser leur
transition économique c'est pour cette
raison que nous vous demandons de nous
accompagner d'accompagner les différents
présidents de région afin de faire
comprendre et entendre au niveau dans
qu'européen qu'il est nécessaire de
continuer à réaliser les infrastructures
donc de base à savoir donc désenclaver
nos régions la question notamment de la
réalisation des groupes scolaires parce
que nous avons besoin d'une jeunesse
formée parce qu'il est évident que nous
devons rendre nos territoires attractifs
afin qu effectivement les entreprises
puissent se positionner sur des
activités innovantes comme fait
effectivement cela demandé dans le cadre
de la stratégie de lisbonne mais
malheureusement nous accumulons toujours
des retards f à structure important dans
nos régions
merci bouche et bien notre séance de
questions cribles est maintenant
terminée je remercie madame la ministre
et l'ensemble de nos collègues qu'ils
soient intervenus ou qu'ils aient
participé
voilà pour cette séance de questions
cribles consacrée aujourd'hui à
l'outre-mer et à l'union européenne
un débat qui intervient alors que 2011 a
été sacrée année des outre mer marie
luce penchard ministre déléguée à
l'outre-mer a dû répondre aux questions
des sénateurs concernant notamment le
statut de mayotte car pour obtenir des
crédits européens et bien il faut que
mayotte en plus d'être un département
devienne une région ultra périphérique
autres questions des sénateurs à
laquelle il espère a dû répondre c'est
également les accords de libre échange
conclus entre certains pays d'amérique
du sud et les dom
ces accords left en effet au des
barrières douanières et permettent à
certains donc produit comme la banane le
sucre ou le rhum qui sont produits à des
coûts inférieurs dans les états
d'amérique du sud et vient d'être
introduit dans les dom d'où une
concurrence déloyale qui a été dénoncé
pour bien sûr prolonger cette discussion
avant d'entamer l'examen
la loppsi 2 je vais accueillir alain
anziani qui est donc sénateur socialiste
de gironde merci alain anziani d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de public sénat
alors la commission finalement est
revenu aux annonces se fait dans le
discours de grenoble par nicolas sarkozy
est ce que le texte de la commission
telle qu'il arrive aujourd'hui en séance
pourrait être votée en l'état par les
socialistes
l'assemblée nationale avait fait de ce
texte un texte qui n'avait aucun sens
aucune efficacité et qui ne se
distinguer que par son agressivité
inutile
la commission des lois à l'unanimité ou
presque a enlevé cette partie agressive
pour nous ça reste un texte qui n'est
pas acceptable
donc on est évidemment favorable au
retour à une certaine sagesse mais en
fait c'est ça jase s'inscrit dans un
texte qui est inutile qui va être le
douzième texte depuis 2002 on n'a pas
besoin de ce texte à quoi sert ce texte
un texte kenny d'orientation ni de
programmation et qui n'a aucun lien avec
les performances de sécurité intérieure
donc c'est un texte pour nous qui est
profondément politique qui en fait plus
fait pour faire un clin d'oeil avec ras
du front national que pour améliorer la
sécurité des français
pourtant il me semble que vous souhaitez
jouer la carte de l'apaisement vous avez
même avez dit que vous étiez contre tout
énervement sécuritaire et il ya un
certain consensus quand même qui se
dégage du texte de la commission
oui je vous dis c'est pas parce que
c'est moins pire que c'est bien donc
c'est moins pire que ça aurait pu être
mais pour nous c'est pas bien en fait
c'est un texte vous avez aussi remarqué
c'est un fourre tout où on passe de
l'identité des personnes décédées à
l'évacuation des campements illicites à
la police sur sur internet à la
vidéoprotection est tous dans ce texte
sauf des priorités sauf des orientations
alors ponctuellement on va pas forcément
être défavorable sur tel ou tel point il
ya des points qui effectivement peuvent
aller dans le bon sens mais globalement
franchement c'est un non sens et surtout
c'est je le dis encore c'est une loi
d'orientation où sont les orientations
une loi de programmation ou et la
programmation
donc pour nous c'est un texte qui est
décevant le seul fil rouge que l'on voit
c'était le discours effectivement
extrêmement sécuritaire de nicolas
sarkozy et nous sommes que même s'il
était un peu raboté par la sagesse td
nateur traditionnels il en reste
suffisamment d'éléments pour que nous
puissions pas le voter sur quelles
dispositions comptez vous revenir quels
sont les amendements des socialistes
justement pour rendre ce texte
acceptable alors on doit déposer une
cinquantaine d'amendements sur un peu
tous les points par exemple on nous
propose d'étendre les peines planchers
c'est à dire que de limiter le pouvoir
du juge aujourd'hui à des peines
plancher qui existe mais pour les non
récidiviste dont il ya des punchs qui
existent uniquement pour les
récidivistes
là on nous propose d'étendre ou non
récidivistes pourquoi on pense
qu'aujourd'hui déjà la peine plancher
n'est pas appliquée appliquant des
chalets texte n'est pas appliquée
pourquoi on va l'étendre à des non
récidivistes même si commission des lois
essayer de faire en sorte qu'on pose des
conditions
ben nous nous proposons la suppression
pure et simple de cette mesure qui sera
inutile même chose sur les peines de
sûreté même source sur la surveillance
judiciaire après la condamnation
regardez par exemple le texte sur les
sur les mineurs il ya beaucoup de
parties sur les mineurs l'assemblée
nationale et le gouvernement prévoyait
que le mineur puisse faire l'objet d'un
couvre feu
c'est dire que le préfet puisse décider
un trophée individuel pour un mineur
nous sommes revenus sur ce point alors
là nous sommes d'accord par exemple pour
le faire effectivement que couvre feu
concernant les mineurs soit une décision
l'autorité judiciaire du juge des
enfants est pas une décision
administrative du du préfet donc là on
va manifester notre accord mais en même
temps quand suite après concernant des
mineurs
on veut détourner aujourd'hui le
tribunal pour enfants et juge des
enfants en disant qu'un mineur pourra
être directement en avant la comparution
immédiate pour les mineurs c'est à dire
que l'officier de police judiciaire
pourra directement convoqué un mineur
devant pour le tri malenfant un mineur
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui avait à voir
14 15 ans mais nous ça nous semble être
une mauvaise mesure quelqu un qu à 14 15
ans qui a fait une bêtise il doit avoir
le juge des enfants il doit avoir une
instruction il doit avoir les mesures
éducatives
il doit pas être directement comme ça
envoyé devant le tribunal comme si au
fond c'était une des solutions
d'abattage pour les mineures qu'il
fallait là où il faut au contraire il
faut des solutions d'éducation
il ya un autre point de ce texte de la
loppsi 2 dont qui avait fait débat en
première lecture au sénat il s'agissait
du permis à points là le sénat ne
souhaite pas rouvrir le débat est ce que
c'est une bonne chose c'est long eh bien
je vais vous dire que je pense que oui
il faut choisir en toute chose et là on
a le choix entre quoi entre d'un côté la
sécurité je pense que c'est notre
priorité
tous tous ceux qui aujourd'hui discute
je comprends bien c'est vrai que vous
perdez votre permis vous pouvez pas
aller travailler vous pouvez pas aller
voir vos enfants vous pouvez pas le voir
vos parents on voit bien les nuisances
quotidiennes
mais quand même si demain à cette même
personne parce qu'elle a continué à
commettre des infractions se retrouvent
paralytique si demain cette même
personne à un accident grave mais je
pense que là elle nous dira au fond la
priorité ça doit être assez connaît donc
pour nous c'est la priorité je crois
d'ailleurs que le sénat à trouver une
formulation assez équilibré parce qu'en
réalité avec le nouveau texte pas grand
chose ne change circle on reconstitue
ces points uniquement que si on a fait
de petites infractions mais toutes les
infractions graves y compris les excès
de vitesse seront en dehors de la
reconstitution des points moi je dis
franchement je pense que c'est bien même
si on comprend que la vie quotidienne
puisse être perturbée alors il ya
d'autres mesures
c'est dire que par exemple le fait qu'on
puisse avoir un stage tous les ans au
lieu de tous les deux ans permettra à la
personne moyens moyens dans un effort au
moins ya aussi une prise de conscience
moyennant une volonté de s'adapter et
bien de récupérer ces coins donc cela va
aussi dans le bon sens je pense que le
texte final et un texte équilibre très
bien aimé écouter merci beaucoup alain
anziani d'avoir répondu en direct aux
questions de public sénat
vous allez donc regagné l'hémicycle dans
un instant je vous le rappelle c'est la
discussion le début de la discussion
générale du projet de loi loppsi 2 qui
va débuter ce soir au sénat peut-être
nous allons accueillir un autre sénateur
merci pour revenir sur les questions
cribles sur le thème de l'outre-mer et
de l'europe c'est le sénateur adrien
giraud sénateurs du groupe union
centriste de mayotte alors vous vous
avez interpellé
marie luce penchard sur le problème du
statut de mayotte liés à la département
lisait départementalisation pour pour
l'instant mayer
n'a pas le statut de région
ultrapériphérique ce qu'ils empêchent
d'obtenir des fonds européens est ce que
vous avez été satisfait par la réponse
que vous avez fait la ministre
d'abord je voudrais remercier notre
ministre parce que notre le ministre
s'emploie vraiment pour aujourd'hui
entreprendre les démarches nécessaires
entre l'europe et la france parce que le
problème c'est l'europe et la france
pour que l' europe accepte aujourd'hui
la doléance française de pouvoir nous
intégrer nouveau département de mayotte
depuis depuis 2010 que nous avons voté à
95 % pour guild 2 le sommes aujourd'hui
le 101e département de la république
donc nous espérons entrer dans des fonds
européens pour pouvoir bénéficier
aujourd'hui des fonds structurels pour
l'année à partir de 2014 parce que nous
entrerons simplement un activités de
dison européenne qu'à partir de 2014
et à quoi servent ces fonds structurels
pour les maoris est visible en ligne les
attendent
oui nous attendons avec beaucoup
d'impatience et ses fonds structurels
parce que vous savez que nous avons par
rapport aux sommes aujourd'hui nous
avons 40 ans ou 50 de retard au point de
vue développement
donc nous voulons rattraper d'abord
cesser ces retards par des grands
instituts investiture comme par exemple
la piste de l'aéroport de la piste
d'aviation de l'amener à 2000 au 2300
comme toutes les pistes pour être aux
normes
nous avons également énormément de leurs
étals sur les routes le nez des travaux
routiers nous avons également de l'étang
dans tous les domaines l'eau
l'électricité et source
tout ceci et nous devons nous voulons
utiliser le sma ces fonds structurels
peau et s'est rattrapé ceux ci adrien
giraud 2011 est l'année des outre mer
comment qualifiez-vous cette initiative
c'est une bonne chose
je pense aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
veut vraiment et c'est de ce devoir que
les outre-mer ont eu beaucoup de retard
par rapport aux neurones par rapport aux
niveaux national et européen par rapport
au niveau national français et je crois
que l'initiative qui a été prise par le
président la république nicolas sarkozy
est une bonne initiative et c'est un
homme qui a toujours respecté ses
paroles c'est un c'est un grand homme
merci adrien giraud d'avoir répondu en
direct aux questions de public sénat
dans un instant donc je vous le disais
nous allons regagné l'hémicycle pour le
début
la discussion générale sur le projet de
loi d'orientation et de la sécurité
intérieure le projet de loi loppsi 2
j'accueille maintenant à mes côtés le
sénateur ump du nord jean rené lecerf
merci donc d'être en direct avec nous
alors finalement la commission des lois
du sénat est revenu à la position du
sénat finalement en première lecture
est ce que c'est une volonté du sénat
d'apaiser les débats de trouver un
consensus sur ce texte
je pensais surtout une volonté du sénat
de rester fidèle à lui même si vous
voulez dans cette loi sur la sécurité
intérieure dans cette fameuse loppsi
il ya bien des points sur lesquels on
est tombé d'accord avec l'assemblée
nationale qu'il s'agisse des problèmes
relatifs à la cybercriminalité à
l'extension des pouvoirs des polices
municipales à la lutte contre la
violence dans les stades
je pourrais en multiplier les exemples
mais il ya un certain nombre de points
sur lesquels le sénat s'était prononcé
déjà dans des solutions de compromis en
première lecture sur lequel l'assemblée
nationale a balayé en quelques sortes
les précautions qui avait prise de ces
nappes et où le sénat rétablit donc en
seconde lecture ses convictions d'il ya
quelques semaines je pense par exemple à
aa3 situation nous estimons que les
propositions ne connecte députés étaient
inconstitutionnels qu'il s'agisse
notamment de la généralisation des
peines plancher à l'égard des primo
délinquants qui nous paraît contraire
affectivement principe de
personnalisation et d'individualisation
effectivement des peines qu'il s'agisse
du couvre feu qui pourrait être décidée
par le préfet donc autorité
administrative alors que c'est bien
l'autorité judiciaire qui est gardienne
fondamentale des libertés donc sur ces
différents points
on pourra également donner l'exemple des
convocations des mineurs par officier de
police judiciaire où nous estimons que
cela risque d'être considérée comme
contraire au principe de spécialité des
procédures à l'égard des mineurs sur ces
différents points donc la commission des
lois ne souhaite pas s'exposer
immédiatement à une censure du conseil
constitutionnel donc allant des revenus
effectivement à ses convictions à
initial et puis il ya d'autres poids sur
les calmes
c'est tout le charme du bicamérisme sur
lesquels nous avons un
une opinion différente de l'opinion de
l'assemblée nationale qu'il s'agisse
d'une espèce de généralisation de peine
de sûreté de trente ans on ça nous
paraît effectivement à ne pas être
opportun et qu'il s'agisse de 2,2 décidé
également de multiplier les peines
totalement imprescriptible lounge
estimant que l' imprescriptibilité cela
concerne les crimes contre l'humanité et
que si on ouvre la boîte de pandore on
dit c'est ce que j'appelle un les
députés voulaient donc l'étendra aux
crimes liés à des disparitions d'enfants
c'est bien ça puis après deux matchs
suite été décret et on contrôle les
représentants de la force publique
et on sait très bien que lorsqu'on
commence effectivement à prévoir une
exception ont généralisé l'exception
donc nous souhaitons rester à la règle
et nous estimons que le dispositif
protecteur qui existait déjà sur ce
point suffisamment fournis jean rené
lecerf la semaine dernière le sénat a
sorti son rapport annuel sur
l'application des lois aujourd'hui
l'opposition dénonce le projet de loi
loppsi 2 comme une loi fourre tout on
sait qu'il ya des difficultés
d'appliquer les lois tant qu'elles ont
tant que les décrets d'application sont
trop nombreux qu'il ya une inflation
législative est ce que justement avec ce
projet de loi loppsi 2 on appelle à un
bon exemple d'une loi qui connaîtra des
difficultés dans son application
alors non seulement elle connaîtra des
mais elle gêne de l'application de lois
précédentes puisque moi j'étais
rapporteur par exemple de loi
pénitentiaire
et figurez vous qu'au bout d'un an soit
loi pénitentiaire on vient juste de
prendre l'intégralité des textes
d'application et l'admiration
pénitentiaire d'ailleurs met tout en
oeuvre pour que la volonté du
législateur soit parfaitement respectée
or cette loi loppsi elle vient dire que
ce qui était prévu en termes
d'aménagements de peine c'est à dire la
possibilité qu'il y ait des aménagements
de peines jusqu'à deux années
d'emprisonnement
et bien tout cela va être d'un revers de
main remis en cause en estimant qu'il y
a là une façon de bégayer un peu notre
législation
et puis de revenir sur un principe fort
de loi pénitentiaire qui était le
principe selon lequel en matière
délictuelle l'emprisonnement et
d'exception et d'aménagement de peine ou
alternative à l'incarcération devient la
règle je signale que nous sommes en
train de gagner le pari de la loi
pénitentiaire les prisons sont moins
débordé aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était
hier la surpopulation carcérale diminue
il y à la construction de nouveaux
établissements qui permet d'accélérer ce
phénomène nous sommes en passe de
pouvoir réussir l'encellulement
individuel à l'époque prévu c'est à dire
1 en 2014 ce sera un succès
extraordinaire s'est inscrit dans la loi
depuis 1875 n'a jamais été réalisé nous
pensons que ce n'est pas le moment de
remettre en cause ses efforts méritoires
qui permette qui permettront rapidement
de mettre fin à ce que le président de
la commission des lois a appelé à l'
humiliation pour la république très bien
et bien écoutez je vous remercie donc
que nous allons dans quelques instants
prendre la direction de l'hémicycle pour
suivre le début de l'examen du projet de
loi loppsi 2 nous attendons donc
l'intervention l'arrivée de brice
hortefeux qui est donc le ministre
concerné par ce projet de loi son
arrivée est imminente dans l'hémicycle
je vais peut-être accueillir un autre
sénateur pour pour donc parler de
l'examen de ce projet de loi je vous
rappelle les principales dispositions
on a dit que c'était un texte
fourre-tout il doit définir les grandes
orientations de la politique sécuritaire
de la france pour les années 2009 2014
il doit donc donner les moyens
à la police et la gendarmerie d'assurer
la sécurité des citoyens
je vous le disais c'est un texte qui va
donc vraiment sur lequel les tensions
entre l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
avant se focaliser peut-être louis
s'il vous plaît si voulez répondre en
direct aux questions de public sénat sur
l'examen du projet de loi loppsi 2 il y
à une disposition qui sur laquelle le
sénat est revenu concernant les
transports
il était prévu que les officiers de
police judiciaire puisse donc à mener
eux mêmes les les agents voilà donc
est-ce que c'est donc ce recul
finalement vous satisfait il semblerait
que le personnel lui-même et donc ses
institutions comme la sncf et demandé le
retrait de ce texte là qui pose des
problèmes d'application on fait donc
autant nous avons été très favorable par
exemple à la condamnation pour rentrer
dans les lieux de conduite des trains
autant cette disposition à paraissait
difficile à appliquer concrètement sur
le terrain
nous voulons être efficaces voilà bien
écoutez je vous laisse ainsi que du
sénat tout de suite donc l'examen du
projet de loi loppsi 2 je vous propose
d'écouter le début de la discussion
générale très bonne séance à tous quatre
mois après sa présentation et sa
première lecture au sénat nous a